Їдеш на перевантаженій фурі - плати штраф. За рік дії закону про габаритно-ваговий контроль з порушників стягнули понад 120 мільйонів гривень.
Проте війні з далекобійниками, яку рік тому оголосив президент Зеленський, назвавши порушників вагових норм "засранцями", ще далеко не кінець.
За оцінками "Укртрансбезпеки", позитивні наслідки у вигляді зменшення кількості порушень є,
але разом з тим кожна четверта фура на українських дорогах усе ще перевантажена.
Далекобійник з Одеси Олег Карпенко вважає винними в цьому не лише водіїв вантажІвок, а й інспЕкторів "Укртрансбезпеки".
Відсотків 50 як возили "перегрузи", так і возять. Корумповані дії від "Укртрансбезпеки" є.
Олег Карпенко їздить у відрядження тепер разом з дружиною.
Тетяна розповідає, що виконувати законодавство щодо дотримання норм вантажів нелегко.
У нас своя машина, і ми не беремо "перегрузи" ніколи. Самі в цьому зацікавлені. Але часто водіїв змушують брати "перегруз".
Ось ми сварилися, писали заяву на заводі в Чернівцях, бо нам сказали, що, мовляв, скільки скажуть, стільки мусимо везти.
А ми сказали, що ні, не на тих натрапили…
З жовтня цього року таких інцидентів вже не має виникати.
Набудуть чинності зміни до закону про габаритно-ваговий контроль на транспорті,
які суттєво посилять відповідальність вантажовідправників і перевізників.
Штрафи зростуть мало не вдвічі: мінімально вісім з половиною тисяч гривень, максимально - п'ятдесят одна тисяча.
Стягувати штрафи вже будуть не лише інспектори "Укртрансбезпеки".
Новий закон передбачає автоматичне нарахування штрафу на підставі показників так званих ВІМІв -
автоматичних ваг, які вмонтовані в траси і можуть зважувати машину в русі.
Якщо окремо взяти авторежим, чим він відрізняється і чим він кращій діючої ситуаціїї…
По-перше, ці комплекси працюють 24 на 7, фіксують і оформлюють і виносять порушення миттєво.
Тому що наш  співробітник витрачає від 20 до 30 хвилин.Для цього  не потрібно зупиняти авто.
І головне - цей комплекс ніколи не візьме хабаря!
Це центральна диспетчерська "Укртрансбезпеки", куди стікається вся інформація про порушення габаритно-вагових норм
майже з усіх 48 ВІМів, що встановлені на українських трасах.
З жовтня стягнення штрафу буде виглядати наступним чином.
Оператор бачить порушення, кілька кліків, протокол готовий за лічені хвилини і відправлений перевізнику.
Поки що ВІМи і диспетчерська працюють у тестовому режимі.
Те, що ми бачимо станом на сьогодні, це взагалі якісь астрономічні цифри.
Якби ми завтра от так включили, то отримали б до 50 млн грв у бюджет на день.
Приміром, цей ВІМ стоїть на під’їзді до Києва. За 10 хвилин їзди від нього - пункт вагового контролю зі стаціонарними вагами.
Інспектори заздалегідь дізнаються про порушника завдяки ВІМу і можуть точково зупиняти для вагового контролю лише ті фури,
на яких зафіксували перевищену вагу. ВІМ фіксує не лише перевищення загальної ваги, але й як розподілено вантаж по осях.
Дороги руйнуються часто саме через те, що вантаж розподілений неправильно.
І за це перевізник також може бути оштрафований, навіть якщо перевозить дозволену вагу.
У нас перевізники не знають, як правильно розподіляти вантаж. Є деякі заводи, які давно працюють і знають, де та який та куди палет ставити.
А є ті, що вантажать "наобум", наставлять по 4 пачки скрізь і виходить перевищення головної осі.
Ще три роки тому  перевізники на це просто взагалі не зважали.
Тепер, щоб не сперечатися з інспекторами і не платити штрафи, водіям довелося швидко вчитися мистецтву завантаження.
Використовують спеціальні датчики для додаткового контролю після завантаження.
Деякі експедиторські компанії придбали нові вантажівки, які мають бортовий комп’ютер, що показує навантаження на осі.
У мене максимальне навантаження йде 24 тони. Я можу пройти по осях, щоб було до 40 тонн, щоб не перевищувати. Зараз я маю 21 210 кг.
То які в мене можуть бути проблеми з транспортною поліцією?..
Одного разу самі неправильно завантажили машину, сплатили штраф 50 євро, навчилися правильно вантажити та й усе.
За годину роботи інспекторів "Укртрансбезпеки" на стаціонарних вагах перед в’їздом до Києва - жодного порушника вагових норм.
Інспектори кажуть, що ситуація за рік дії суворих правил суттєво покращилася. Але не лише тому, що водії стали сумлінніші.
Ми їдемо, а в рацію вже кажуть, що інспекція їде в такий-то бік, що, мовляв, будьте уважні. Це боротьба і гра в кішки-мишки.
ВІМ зафіксував вантажІвку, має майже 10 тонн перевищення ваги. Але по дорозі до пункту перевірки інспекторів фура зникає.
Або з'їхала в кущі, або десь стоїть і чекає обідньої перерви інспекторів або завершення їхньої зміни о 5-ій вечора.
Але якщо біля Києва обдурити інспекторів й електронні вАги все ж таки не так просто, то якщо від'їхати від столиці подалі, картина вже зовсім інша.
Ми знаходимося на стратегічному зерновому перехресті України. Зерновози з  Києва, Умані та Черкас везуть вантажі в південні порти України.
Цього року тут не фіксують таких антирекордів, як торік, коли вантажівки возили до 100 000 тонн та більше.
Місцеві інспектори "Укртрансбезпеки" на пункті контрою працюють цілодобово, але перевіряти всі вантажівки не можуть.
Інспектори біля Умані, на відміну від київських колег, не мають ані підключених ВІМів - найближчий стоїть за 20 хвилин їзди звідси, ані стаціонарних ваг.
Лише пересувні, які, приміром, не можна використовувати в дощ або для зважування машин, що перевозять бетон чи інші рідкі субстанції.
Скільки машин об’їжджають "зернове перехрестя" кущами або сільськими дорогами, можна лише здогадуватися.
Інспектори покладають великі сподівання на запуск ВІМІв, які тут мають підключити восени.
Будемо сподіватися, що ВІМи нам ще більше допоможуть. Це одне з ключових завдань, щоб вони працювали,
тому що  інспектори не можуть все контролювати, фізично не встигають...
Рік тому президент Зеленський назвав далекобійників, що руйнують українські дороги, "засранцями". Водії йому цього не забули.
Засранці їздять крізь ліси.
Що ми вибрали, то і маємо. Не можна народ так називати!
Треба штрафи підняти ще раз і всіх зупиняти, незважаючи чи є там якісь плечі за кимось.
Головне, щоб зробили ці електронні ваги. В цифровому форматі прийшов тоді штраф…
Нове законодавство  дає більше можливостей ловити перевантажені фури по кущах та селах, де взагалі заборонено їздити таким транспортом.
Щодо об’їзду, то для цього є наші пересувні ваги. Для цього є поліція, яка має не допускати фури на дороги місцевого значення.
Ми будемо розгортати наші комплекси в місцях, де можна об’їхати. І впевнений, що це ганебне явище піде на спад.
На сьогодні це дійсно масштабне порушення, яке вже стало звичкою.
Цю погану звичку можна побороти додатковими ВІМами, переконані в "Укртрансбезпеці".
До кінця року на українських трасах встановлять ще 50 таких приладів.
Та чи вистачить цього, щоб примирити президента Зеленського з далекобійниками, покаже час.